[Musique]
vous êtes sur France 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'Afrique à la une ce soir j-2 avant la
Coupe du monde de football au Qatar page
spécial dans ce journal trois lions un
aigle et une étoile quels sont les
chances des équipes du Sénégal du
Cameroun du Maroc Tunisie et de Ghana
dans cette compétition vous saurez tout
grâce à notre chroniqueur sport et
l'homme to blé
va-t-on vers un tournant dans la guerre
qui oppose au gouvernement congolais au
rebelle du M23 pour la première fois le
président rwandais a accepté de demander
un cesser le feu aux rebelles qui
terrorise l'Est de la RDC depuis une
dizaine d'années les explications à
suivre dans ce journal
nous irons sur l'île de Djerba en
Tunisie à la veille du XVIIIe Sommet de
la Francophonie près de 60 chefs d'états
sont attendus entretien exclusif avec la
secrétaire général de l'Organisation
extrait à suivre
on ouvre ce journal une fois n'est pas
coutume par le bus sport à deux jours de
l'ouverture de la Coupe du monde de
football au Qatar ce dimanche 32 équipes
vont s'affronter pendant un mois parmi
lesquels 5 équipes africaines sont leurs
chances justement nous avons la chance
d'avoir elon Tobler notre chroniqueurs
sport merci alors d'être là bonsoir
Fatimata alors vous allez nous parler
des équipes africaines qualifiées mais
on commence évidemment par cette
déception pour tout un pays les Lions de
la Téranga sont qui joueront sans Sadio
Mane n'y sera pas malheureusement c'est
c'est un crève-cœur pour tous les
Sénégalais malgré toute leur prière
finalement Sadio Mane ne sera pas à ce
Mondial on les on écoute d'ailleurs leur
réactions aujourd'hui à Dakar envoyer
par nos correspondants sur place
sur le terrain et on a eu un sentiment
de désolation sentiment de tristesse en
apprenant que Sadio Mané définitivement
forfait pour la Coupe du Monde nous
savons que c'est quelqu'un qui s'y
préparer qui vraiment voulu jouer cette
Coupe du Monde qui peut-être sera sa
dernière parce qu'il commence à prendre
l'âge donc on l'a appelé avec beaucoup
de tristesse une équipe du Sénégal sans
Sadio Mané c'est vrai que c'est comme du
repas sans sel sans
chargement l'équipe a quand même
d'autres bons joueurs j'ai espoir
qu'elle fera mieux qu'en 2002 où
l'équipe avait fait un bon parcours je
pense que les lions iront même en finale
inch'Allah
mais les autres ils seront alors
dites-nous que réserve le programme
justement aux équipes africaines on va
commencer par le Sénégal de Sadio Mane
du coup sans Sadio Mané très difficile
vous pouvez voir donc le Sénégal est
dans le groupe du pays organisateur qui
est le Qatar il est donc le Qatar
l'équateur et les Pays Bas au programme
pour les Sénégalais qui ouvrent
d'ailleurs le bal pour les équipes
africaines puisque ce lundi le Sénégal
affrontera les Pays-Bas ce match est
déjà décisif pour le Sénégal parce que
en l'absence de Sadio Mané il va falloir
engranger des points dès les premiers
matchs et dès ce match face au Pays-Bas
ensuite sur le papier le Sénégal devrait
battre l'équateur et aussi le Qatar mais
ce n'est jamais facile de jouer face aux
pays organisateur mais surtout le
problème pour le Sénégal c'est en fait
imaginer le Brésil jouer son Neymar la
France en Mbappé c'est exactement le
même problème qu'aliou Cissé aujourd'hui
en gros on construit une équipe autour
de telle star et Sadio Mane est arrivé
deuxième au Ballon d'Or donc c'est l'une
des plus grandes stars du monde du
football et c'est normal de construire
son équipe autour de Sadio Mané ce genre
de joueurs ce sont des joueurs
exceptionnels donc à Lucie se retrouve
du jour au lendemain sans sa star il va
devoir repenser tout un groupe après la
force d'aller aussi c'est qu'il a réussi
à construire un groupe plutôt uni je
tirer un peu la quintessence de chaque
individualité il va falloir encore plus
que le Sénégal joue en fait en équipe
pour combler le vide laissé par manie
alors quelles sont les meilleures
chances de qualification pour les
équipes africaines alors j'ai envie de
dire que cette année j'ai envie les
équipes africaines ne sont pas du tout
gâtés parce que si on regarde les
différents groupes peut-être le Sénégal
peut sortir de sa phase de groupe mais
ensuite quand on voit par exemple la
Tunisie qui va affronter la France
l'Australie le Danemark déjà ça paraît
un petit peu plus compliqué
pire encore quand on voit le groupe du
Cameroun qui a le Brésil la Serbie et la
Suisse alors les Ghanéens sont les plus
mal l'outils parce que il y a le
Portugal il y a l'Uruguay et la Corée du
Sud on se demande comment le Ghana va
réussir à sortir de cette poule le Maroc
lui devra affronter la Belgique le
Canada et la Croatie donc ça a l'air
très mal embarqué sur le papier mais
alors est-ce que pour une fois à une
équipe sénégalaise enfin pour une fois
est-ce que oui pour une fois est-ce
qu'une Égypte sénégalaise peut se
retrouver en demi-finale c'est tout
c'est tout le qu'on espère pour le
Sénégal et même pour toutes les équipes
africaines finalement qu'ils ont
présentes à ce tournoi parce que
peut-être que l'absence de manie c'est
ce que tout le monde espère va faire que
tous les joueurs vont se sublimer et ou
peut-être d'autres joueurs vont se
révéler on passe par exemple à pour le
Sénégal à quelqu'un comme Ismaïla Sark
qui depuis qu'il a éclaté au plus haut
niveau on attend beaucoup de lui on se
souvient déjà que à la canne à Lucie est
parti avec lui blessé et même s'il a
plus commencé à jouer qu'en demi-finale
donc est-ce qu'il va se sublimer pour
porter le Sénégal est-ce que d'autres
joueurs vont se révéler c'est ce qu'on
espère mais ça ça paraît compliqué sur
le papier mais on suivra ça évidemment
et avec vous entre autres sur les
antennes de France 24 merci beaucoup
elon toblade d'être venu pour nous
parler des chances des équipes
africaines au mondiales de football qui
s'ouvre ce dimanche au Qatar et alors
l'autre actualité de la soirée c'est le
président rwandais Paul Kagame qui a
accepté de demander au rebelles lui M23
de CCD tirs et de se retirer des
territoires conquis de l'Est du Congo
déclaration faite à l'ancien président
où on retrouve notre correspondant
bassin romain
n'est pas d'affronter le M23 ils sont
plutôt là pour aider à la démobilisation
des combattants donc impossible de dire
s'ils pourront reprendre ces zones
actuellement contrôlées par le M23 et
s'ils accepteront deux combattre le cas
échéant ensuite et bien comment les
tensions vont-elles pouvoir diminuer
dans cette région elles sont extrêmement
fortes vous le savez le président
congolais Félix thieces homologue rondé
bien de soutenir et d'armer le M23 les
tensions sont très fortes entre les deux
pays deux pays qui doivent se retrouver
la semaine prochaine pour le sommet de
Luanda 2 alors nul doute que se
communiquer est d'une très grande
importance puisque les officiels
congolais et rwandais doivent négocier
pour permettre d'apporter une paix
durable dans l'Est de la RDC
le 18e sommet de la Francophonie s'ouvre
demain sur l'île de Djerba en Tunisie
l'événement réunira une trentaine de
chefs d'État et de membres de l'OIF et
il marquera entre autres le début de la
présidence tunisienne de l'organisation
France 24 RFI ont interviewé la
secrétaire général de l'Organisation
louise Mushikiwabo notre envoyé spécial
Marc Perelman revient sur cette
entretien
le 18e sommet de la Francophonie s'ouvre
ici à Djerba en Tunisie sa secrétaire
général louise Mushikiwabo se dit
inquiète de la prolifération des coups
d'État dans l'Afrique francophone elle
s'exprimait à l'antenne de France 24 et
de RFI d'abord c'est une situation qui
me désole moi en tant que secrétaire
général de la Francophonie parce que ce
sont nos pays membres mais en même temps
je crois qu'il faut être
réaliste par rapport à la situation
politique dans le monde je pense que je
ne me trompe pas si je dis que le monde
va mal et ça ça comprend le monde
francophone aussi nous avons d'autres
pays puisque vous parlez du continent
nous avons l'Éthiopie nous avons le
Mozambique c'est pas des pays
francophones
ceci dit
les coups d'État qui reviennent sur le
continent c'est quand même perturbant je
trouve que notre organisation de toutes
les crises que nous avons eu cette année
le Tchad et le pays où nous avons
beaucoup investi nous continuons nous
restons présents
que ce soit dans dans le chemin du
retour à la Constitution mais vous savez
ce ne sont pas des organisations
multilatérales ou internationales qui
vont changer la vie politique de nos
pays ce sont les dirigeants des pays et
ce sont les citoyens des pays cette
question sera au cœur d'un huis clos
entre les chefs d'État et de
gouvernement ici à Djerba de son côté
louise Mushikiwabo sera réélu pour un
mandat de 4 ans à la tête de la
Francophonie
on reste en Tunisie car le pays connaît
aussi une recrudescence de spectacle
d'humoriste ces dernières années et pas
seulement un dialectes locales à
l'occasion d'un premier festival du Mont
francophone normal Andy et qui s'est
tenu le mois d'octobre à Tunis l'ilia
Blaise et sont allés à la rencontre de
ces artistes qui arrivent à faire rire
au-delà des frontières de leur pays
sur scène avant le spectacle Adèle
répète timidement ses sketchs il ne veut
pas tout dévoiler pendant les
répétitions ce Français d'origine
algérienne se produit pour la deuxième
fois en Tunisie où il commence à trouver
son public
je sais pas très parisien c'est pas
français français moi par exemple je
parle des visages 15 que tu en as tous
un visage et c'est un truc tout con mais
qui parle à tout le monde et qui
rassemble les gens les visages je parle
des poules aussi on a tout on attendait
tous c'est quoi des poules Adèle a été
révélée en Tunisie grâce à une résidence
du Maurice francophone l'initiative
pharaoni qui s'est déroulée en mai
dernier c'était super enrichissant ça
permet de voir qu'on pouvait se
comprendre quoi qu'on pouvait rigoler
des mêmes choses même si on habite pas
au même endroit
et devant le public Adèle enchaîne les
références
une catégorie de Jean-Jacques
je crois que oui
mais ils sont ils sont là ils sont
à l'arrêt
mais tu conduis une voiture ou un
taureau à ses côtés deux humoristes
sénégalais le duo balladium Willy qui se
produit pour la première fois dans le
pays
alors bonsoir les femmes des blagues qui
séduisent le public tunisien malgré des
différences culturelles c'est très
intéressant comme distance oui c'est des
rires assez différents le rire algérien
le rire sénégalais le rire belge pour
les organisateurs du festival il s'agit
de valoriser le français en perte de
vitesse dans le pays et on a choisi
l'humour pour faire redémarrer cette
chose là pour démystifier un peu cette
ce problème de langue qui n'est pas un
problème qui doit être justement une
solution le Sommet de la Francophonie a
aussi mis à l'honneur de nombreux
artistes francophones et des
partenariats culturels et éducatifs pour
faire perdurer l'apprentissage du
français
et sur ces images que l'on se quitte
merci à tous ceux qui nous ont suivis
partout où ils sont de Dakar à Djerba en
passant par Nairobi et bonne chance à
toutes les équipes africaines et toutes
les autres évidemment dans la
compétition merci et restez avec nous
car l'actualité continue sur France 24
[Musique]
France 24 l'art sous toutes ses formes
liberté égalité Actualité Actualité
événement
duel de titan au Qatar
[Applaudissements]
les plus grands joueurs de la planète
s'affrontent pour la Coupe du monde
du 20 novembre 18 décembre suivez Le
Journal du Mondial chaque jour sur
France 24 et France 24 com
sur France 24 retrouver des entretiens
exclusifs avec les personnalités les
plus influentes du monde
des rencontres avec les plus grands
leaders politiques l'inquiétude elle est
extrême des acteurs de la scène
culturelle sportive ou encore
scientifiques la science la recherche la
découverte le progrès c'est important
c'est pas des c'est pas des mots qui
sont vides
la croisée des idées c'est dans
entretien sur France 24 et France 24
liberté égalité actualité